what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation we are here to do part
three of our cutscenes reaction
featuring a little bit of gameplay for
necessary story for Spider-Man 2 I'm
really enjoying this and I was
reflecting on it of a big part of why
I'm enjoying it too is because if we
ever the rare times decide to review a
game here find myself like rushing
through it and not really being able to
take it in cuz like I got to review this
and now that I can just take in the
story then I could really slow down and
enjoy the game and enjoy the side
missions and just really take my time
because it usually takes me 40 hours
anyway way to at least beat one game
there efficient way to get you guys
coverage of it and oh my God we just
heard something clink Andrew he just
picked up Spider-Man too from the UPS
store because he got a big special box
show them the Box first Andrew so it
came in this massive box yeah show them
the show them the good side of the bo
what do you don't you understand
presentation and it came in this special
special little Edition oh my God oh my
God it's so beautiful Andrew what did
you just assemble so you could show them
on camera took me so long to assemble
show show them Andre show them show them
oh yeah that's sexy man is that better
presentation is so much better
presentation you did a great job here
learn from the errors of my ways all
right good now if you do a terrible job
in this reaction you got to give it to
me okay fair enough all right fair
enough don't be surprised if it breaks
don't be surprised if Greg gets a little
bit uh Snappy get a little petty over a
little bit of jealousy Bo I told him he
could have the box so pretty good
compromise yeah I'll put Jon's boring
stuff in there alrighty guys flip that
like button let's continue this
[Music]
reaction what the hell happened here
this is why he becomes a Green Goblin um
this disappointment in his son's cleanly
habits this one event doing some
experiments where's Dr
Connor uh maybe he took the day
off
no he doesn't take days off oh Craven
get to
him I'm going to go or no or maybe he's
just lizardy around I'll call you later
yeah hey guys I'm getting a strange
spiderbot signal you got that too I was
just about to call you guys bunch of
them just pinged the network out of
nowhere using some funky Wireless
protocols I'll check it out and let you
know what I find I mean I already love
the Rapport between him in miles but now
with gy the addition it's just really
works this it's just such a seamless
transition the three of
them looking
sharp Spider-Man 209 9 hey 299 spiderbot
yeah I didn't catch that what's Harry's
radioactive spider I've never seen
anything like this before it's some kind
of exos suit that completely eradicates
any trace of his disease Dr Conor's
really outdid himself this time so he
really needs the he really needs it to
stay alive hey spiders got something for
you head to this location ficia she
calling from Paris yeah right chatter
about the steel foundry in Williamsburg
off a radio I swiped from those Hunters
sounds like tombstone's there he could
use your help thanks I think tombstone's
a good good guy this this time around
well if you remember the uh in the
battle Spider-Man fought with him it
took away his powers miles let me take
this one you're going to miss your essay
deadline what if if Lee's there I'll
take care of him Spider-Man can wait
miles
can't Co wow yeah through the bridge
that's so
sick
woohoo this is so cool seeing all this
unexplored areas that we couldn't go to
in either of the last two oh
PR sick for an abandoned Foundry this
place sure is active what is taking them
so long extra precautions tombstone has
proven challenging right stay ready hunt
to live live to hunt I like that I don't
know hunt to live live to hunt that
should be our motto react to live live
to react you're supposed to let me
finish there Greg you guys just can't
make it
easy oh my goodness oh my
goodness Harry what are you doing here
he's like Agent Venom yeah
way I was hoping to do this quietly is
this my fault do you still think he's
Venom like at that
size I'll distracted get up
there you really has bonded with it very
well
yeah this is cool to see them working
together now yeah that was fun now let's
go rescue a super
villain this is really
unexpected watch
out oh loud noises I'm
stuck Harry you with me good
catch my head we need to move Now is it
going to abandon Harry
oh
get him out of
there H wonder if Harry was unaware of
that
weakness maybe if we don't move it won't
see
us there are three Spider-Man now
they're
here are they gone just in time to shut
down the
furnace I actually like the way the cut
scene is done because it makes me itch
to want to see the gameplay of it
totally but then I'm like oh yeah that
reserves it for me for sure exactly glad
they're saving it for
us you trying to kill everyone here
wasn't the plan
[Music]
sorry they don't quit wet well neither
do
we this whole place is going down I
can't break through the cage maybe we we
go through the
furnace no it's tooo hot in there you
got any better ideas hard choices
right what are you doing oh wow Harry
goes head first Into the Fire Harry's a
real hero
interesting Symbio usually prays on
Darkness right and Har just really seems
like he's like doing doing really good
you know yeah but for how long that's
the
question save him Tombstone get out of
there actually really like that suit oh
damn awesome I really like Harry's suit
it's pretty cool let's go follow
him wow was
like really feels like kind of
allegorical for like the most physical
manifestation of trauma
bonding is this job always so stressful
yoga's done wonders for my mental health
who try to die here move it
no no no no no we lost him don't panic
quick this way woohoo
wow cinematography is so incredible
great camera
movements I love these shots I love
these shots
yes
wow
well
done it's got to be an Agent Venom
tribute hell yeah can you see if we were
followed on
it only downside to going
straight the game keeps you in shape
glad we got to you in time some of the
others weren't so
lucky they couldn't have off me if they
tried sides they were waiting for their
boss to do the
deed
you have someplace safe to go yeah they
come for me again I'll be ready
Tombstone DLC tell your friend thanks
for looking out for
me see you
around
spider interesting to see him get a
Redemption
Arc looks like they split we should too
that's why Spider-Man does what he
does sees the good in
everyone hey good job back there really
I was pretty sure I was just messing
everything up you were but in the best
possible
way I love
this what are you what what hold
on oh I really appreciate this game for
honing in so much on the good of Harry
you know a lot of times in in certain
mediums I feel like they what do you
mean they're kind of like teasing too
much the darkness in Harry or
something huh I guess I
did would you look at that oo a tastes
of the bond guess we really are spider
Pals
now I think I'm going to head back to
the lab see if Dr Connor has showed up
yet good call I'll catch up with you
soon
damn
Incredible Hulk imagine two nerds just
getting the Ultimate Fantasy coming to
life this will make such a difference
for the community thank you so much for
your
support okay I had to explain to my
boyfriend what happened to you how dare
you hey
Ma I just wanted to check in see how
you're
doing
fine everything's
good mom always knows okay it's just a
lot right
now so much to take care of in the
city super stressed about my college
essay Pete's busy doing other stuff I
really love that she
knows gives you a completely different
side so it's especially like he has
someone to confide
in of course it bothers me
but I'm committed to making this
community
better I've got to let go of things that
don't serve me and focus on where I want
to go not where I've
been but Jefferson's killer is out
there
yeah but
Lee I can't just let him go well we saw
in Last of Us Part Two revenge is always
worth out oh
totally
boyfriend Angela I'm going to have to
call you back no how can you be locked
out you have a
key oh no no I I understand the
urgency uh let me make some
calls okay campaign
manager mom do you need me to
go didn't you just finish telling me how
busy you
are yeah but but I always have time for
my
community you are an inspiration miles I
would not be
you I would be napping how can I donate
to a museum where the security system
isn't even functional Darren I hear your
concerns but I assure you this Museum
will Spider-Man oh thank God the systems
locked us out and it's not responding to
any in at all oh that's who the mom was
just talking to Angela y
y relays are overloaded got to get
inside the walls to fix them oh he's got
some spiderbots too now
sick aort
let's there's a criminal activity going
down here almost feel like he doesn't
have Peter to confide in right now and
he's on his own yeah the story lines
have been very separate so
far whoa that looks so cool
yeah dude the camera
work unbelievable what theyve done in
this
game look at the glitch yeah I saw that
I saw that I did see
that there goes our best hope for a big
donor without an exhibit there is no
Gala without a Gala
the museum will have to
close that won't happen I
promise
here this belonged to Clyde
Stubblefield oh the original funky
drummer do you know how often his
rhythms were
sampled it was so influential a direct
line from Funk to Hip Hop I was well
aware of this history I should check in
with
Pete really do love when they do that
tracking shot when then you switch to a
different
player so
cool and I like establishing the
distance between them to show that kind
of an essentialness of the are they are
protecting two completely different
sides of New York right now MJ Bad News
Conor's house is crawling with hunters
and the doctor's Mia
uhoh good news I think I know where to
find
him somewhere across the
river is this what we this looks like
the game playay footage that we saw
yeah let's move he's
waiting yikes oh MJ's just right in
there she is not afraid to get close in
on the action and she left her cell
phone on the ground
[Music]
ham got my Taser we're
good a
rhino I'll get the
gear rest in peace rhino fin took care
of
him damn got this MJ oh my God MJ
whooped their asses yeah right she's
better than the
hunters I'm really curious for that game
play
[Music]
now
wait oh my
God uh this is no bueno you know this
Beast his name is Kurt Conor the sound
design of how he moved there he's a good
man there an
implication there are no good
men
only oh he's turning him into the
lizard dude he is so intimidating I love
it
oh no oh this poor
guy oh that's
cruel that's so
cruel wow just at the last
second you definitely were
late are you two all right better
now there there's a lab in the atrium
might have
a
Ser I don't have much time then we'll
find you
some right up the hill the darker the
story gets the better it gets yeah I'm
keep your heads down curious why Peter
didn't invite miles too but maybe he
feels he's emotionally compromised with
everything but cover
you oh this this this I can
use this to make an
antidote oh you can see his skin is
already
turning he's
here oh man they definitely got more of
like the horror monster vibing this one
around like starting off with Sandman to
this yeah totally I'm
sorry a he's apologizing that's so bad
oh that is creepy how tragic
oh
damn
damn oh damn does Harry Dam does Harry
give it to
him not this venomous as they say
venomous
whoa
whoa oh this is
awesome oh with the fire and the wetness
of this looks like last of us
too the bleakness of the
situation how harrowing it is come on
I'm going to get you out of
here this what you do to him not great
damn love having this fight going on
this will definitely be your coolest
there was like Last of Us Vibes this
isn't oh for sure MJ I don't think makes
sense too we got Laura Bailey we got
Abby right
here I'll kill you
Harry do it
then oh oh oh
oh wow MJ you got really lucky oh
my goodness dude Harry's pretty imposing
himself it's okay come
on I can't I can't see oh man but this
is probably praying on the darkness
within Harry right now yeah one foot in
front of the other think come
on sorry I was always so busy I love the
desperation of this moment you have this
fight going on in the background that is
great
Pete talk to
me
almost there hang on hang on it's a
testament to the storytelling how you
don't have to be behind the controller
and how gripping this can
[Music]
be come on get up get up
Spider-Man how's that for a good
challenge Craven
Pete please stay with
us this is like Spider-Man 3 the movie
Just In Reverse now yeah come on this is
nothing remember in fifth grade when
you oh my god oh symed him
up no you got to stay awake
buddy
[Music]
no symbiote him
up oh Oh I thought it was going to be
like a tear symbiote yeah I was thinking
that too here it is the healing
agent but is it going to leave him or oh
it's leaving him bonding with Pete but
that would kill har kill Harry yeah he
needs it to
live wow it's like literally
resurrecting him he's becoming reborn
that's
crazy
wow I don't
know oh man that would Pete needed to
live you know what I mean yeah you mean
after if it leaves him later I'll handle
this yeah or maybe it it's healed him by
now oh I love the
pain
W
yo oh get your boss needs better aim oh
my God you're reload all just damn he
just went full dark all of a sudden
yeah God this is what I wanted in
Spider-Man 3 just what Craven has been
searching for and I feel sorry for him
whoa he has gone full
SAS oh my God God yeah you he's not
holding back on these punches ah the
rage oh my God
oh my God the sound design dude train
for
this woo this is a blast
T I mean if those guys are not dead he
uh has given them some bad
injuries wow talk that suit is I'm not
even behind the controller and I felt
the catharsis of that
M that suit is so
amazing
he went completely to the darkness like
right
away it's like when he died the good in
him left yeah know usually you feel like
there's a buildup to him with the dark
not even Harry yeah is
mine yeah cuz Harry was able to control
it and still able to cuz you felt like
Harry didn't have much Darkness brewing
in him with
it oh no stop hovering I'm
fine got to pass it back to him man
maybe some water water on
it
so the suit cared your yeah which means
without it
you
yeah that is a
conflict okay we got to figure out how
to get this back onto
Harry how did you give it to
me I I don't know it just chose you sort
of
happened okay uh I love this portrayal
of Harry yeah probably one of my
favorite ones I think it's my I think
it's my favorite
yeah he just feels like a real guy you
notice uh it's tried to like bond with
Pete so many different times oh Stab
Wound okay not what I what the are you
okay I'm fine I'm fine let me try it
again maybe you have to do it with loud
noises I I mean at least that's what we
saw in the movie in Spider-Man 3 I don't
know I don't think I don't think Pete
really wants to give it
up it doesn't really want doesn't want
Harry anymore I I don't know what to do
we need to find Dr
Connors except he's a drilling reptile
right
now
Craven the serum he had it around his
neck that's what he used on Dr Connor if
we find that serum we we could analyze
it use the equipment here to to engineer
a cure and bring this is intense man
this is intense start tracking D Craven
what a buildup he probably already
cleared out of that Zoo by now well
lucky for
us he left a piece of himself
behind
damn love it love
[Music]
it looks like a busy night hope our VIP
is here they're more red up than usual
just keep your head down how are you
getting in kitchen entrance don't be
ungrateful for that job Peter Parker
look is isn't going to cut it too bad my
tux is at the dry
cleaners
huh what is it going to change for
him that is
amazing Whoa We Are
suited who it's like James Bond yeah
spider spy SPID
spy you forget to mention the into a tux
Peter Parker
me it's like a girlfriend they're
sharing now he's getting jealous hey hey
you come over
here give him a vodka martini shaking
not stirred his bodyguard Dima move I
love how the management staff and these
never know who their employees are I was
like hey you're an off go go do
this
Swanky love that Craven needs a
bodyguard excuse
me establish this club as our stronghold
I love seeing The Prestige of Craven it
reminds him of home it's a luxurious
lifestyle he lives yeah keep moving I'll
break it's like a barbaric rich man a
300y old D will never work you are so
certain oh you show me then old school
class I'll show him too
yes
take let him squirm the poison is
ancient and you don't even know how to
use use that
thing oh
jeez oh
jeez well my friend those Hunters were
nuts wish my suit had a neural interface
like this uh-oh I could work with Harry
do the hero gig and take a vacation all
at once did you see he
when time comes is he going to give it
up again I'm really liking how they
capture The Wonder of the has one of the
shield batters arrived uh yes he is in
the other room by the fire will Mr
Kraven off be joining us this evening
there are some
uh quite
right I wish they would have got Bruce
Campbell for the matri
D that would have been the greatest
Easter egg ever sounds like a bodyguard
to me that's what I said
P your meal
sir e in a one fight looks like Iron
Monger right what the hell is this um I
was told to deliver this to Mr Kraven
off's personal bodyguard what makes you
think I am
him you know you're uh
huge dea's very hungry
you should leave now so funny I was just
about to do
that leave now he was looking up at that
room got to find the
elevator if that's just the shield
Bearer how B is Dima going to be coming
through sorry don't be sorry move coming
through oh my
God uh this this mess if everything is
imperfect we're all dead coming through
no no no wait oh my
God why were you standing right in front
of the door I told you to wait you
didn't I was just minding my own come on
shut up both of you pick everything up
and let's
move it's interesting even though he's
got the suit with them it's still a lot
of suspense in tension
here the
drums find dimma we find Craven in his
weird blizzard
serum
easy just love all the offscreen
violence that's happening
yeah that's DEA you wouldn't happen to
be
DEA crap well that explains the secret
menu That's Craven's personal bodyguard
angry a tiger that's
new all right let's give dimma something
to eat that isn't spider flavored that
raw meat must be
somewhere there we
are you're very yeah this is an
interesting Mission getting some raw
meat wao oh that's cool I know we saw
that in the game play uh that we reacted
to earlier Russian tiger bodyguard that
sounded
weird might have to make a few minor
adjustments to this meal sure who's that
sleeping
Hunter oh he's going to put some
tranquilizer in the
meat clearly the writers saw the
hangover
Secret sleepy time for dimma snooping
time for
Peter if this doesn't work there's only
one other thing on the
menu
me I love the corniness of
Peter so
relatable back get a little snacky
[Music]
snack how long will it take to knock out
Dima
it's pretty great effects in the tiger
man WAOW what a crazy upside down
spinning shot guess not very long a chef
Spidey
Masterpiece guess Craven's too cool for
his own party is he really there look
around in case he left the lizard serum
somewhere in here
maybe this is him luring out he's
hunting him right
now my thoughts
exactly no
serum these drugs are for late stage
chemotherapy are these Cravens
too the mother opened every hunt with
these words others spent the night
feasting drinking themselves into
Oblivion not us not the Craven house I
did not read fast enough Chapel prepared
but your accent was on point don't see
Craven's lizard serum here but what are
these
potions they're the enhancements that
give Craven his
[Music]
strength
it's not what it looks
[Music]
like keep him
alive reserving it for
us yo
whoa oh my God it's kind of gross isn't
it
gross and
cool no oh
no oh no be oh
no that wasn't me oh starting to feel
the effects the darkness B bra that you
should I
that the danas
cool we'll have to
subscribe it's quiet little too
quiet understood that
reference you brute son of a
well he doesn't need
those okay webs are back it's you I knew
that was our meat cute back there I knew
it oh oh man it's okay I'd rather they
save it for us anyways it's all good
good oh go to the church post him
getting the Symbio here to pick up a
serum order the cut scenes are so good
though that when you like go back into
it you you don't even like think about
the game
play it's like
Daredevil the Ben Affleck
version they got the bell and everything
cool did make an Easter egg reference to
uh you have hunted Daredevil in the
first
game this is
good every shot is like a painting with
him if you have the strength to finish
what you
started I love the theme music for
Craven I see a
man i s a
beast his lines are a little
repetitive oh the sound
uh-oh it is like classic Venom setup
means that Daredevil
fighting oh yeah good point sound hurts
Matt Murdock
yeah I'm just here to save my
friend oh Craven is fast at adapting to
situations now you can hear the BAM
squeal so is Peter
we'll finish this
later I feel like obviously I'm making
an obvious statement but the more he
holds on to that suit he's not going to
be able to fight the
[Music]
darkness what a interesting shot no
captur in slowmo too but I love how
they're taking their time building up
that Darkness though
really good first he kind of sprang Into
Darkness now building it up it's got
yeah no no no I mean at least from a
action perspective but I mean just
character-wise yeah they're taking their
time
though you still got
it let's see what this thing's made
[Music]
of curious too if we're going to get to
see Norman turn into Green Goblin in
this game but I saving up Pro three
there huz might be the Easter egg at the
end wait does the structure look
unstable to you
sure Greg and I study this all the time
we know if we could beam a few electrons
in there it had stabilize it but it's
not like we have a a Venom Blaster
particle accelerator particle
accelerator it's real that'd be like
using a shotgun for a
haircut they need an arc reactor Greg
I love their childlike kinship it almost
reminds me too of miles and Finn yeah
how close they were and the nerdiness of
their friendship also two miles in gy
reminds me of you and
John okay
totally no black holes no black holes no
black
holes The
Flash glad you made that reference
because we do have the zoom in this game
the voice of Zoom at least Tony Todd
pressure change popped an intersection
out of alignment there's no way to fix
it without going
inside dude I love those transition
changes they're so good the suit will
protect me you know exactly what he's
doing
Peter I don't know about this relax and
be a good
proton
huh stay positive
[Laughter]
my favorite favorite favorite line so
far St PA be a good proton stay positive
you got to crawl in this when you get
the suit back oh yeah it's at the top of
my list what's going to happen when I
realign It Anyway there aren't any other
pressure problems nothing you can come
right
[Music]
out are you still convinced uh
prediction wise that uh Venom is going
to be hary I think it'd be too late to
introduce Eddie Brock honestly well no I
meant like it could be also Craven
possibly just the impose how big he is
sweet spot particle accelerators do not
have sweet
spots now the
other there good wow they're making
science look so
awesome is it working lizard Andy do
Here We
Come
O so the suit's got some sensitive ears
apparently what
happened more static discharges the
accelerator's still running though the
serum's
okay fire you know I really wish you
would have said that stay positive line
to Mar Lee more
often you get that side I'll get this
side oh oh they
attacked
who I didn't know there were bears in
these
Woods use the bee thing okay before we
get down to business there's something I
have to tell you
I'm fresh out of
honey
[Music]
damn come on I thought it was
funny oh it's cool they give a health
bar for the uh
villains
[Music]
damn they are messing up their place I
know
I mean obviously it can be rebuilt
cuz uh are Norman might but
still oh no oh my God oh my God this is
like
everything oh yes
man Ken's really sending a lot of his
goons yeah he has quite a few as
well remember MJ got in that Vance
wonder when she's going to come into
play what MJ remember she was in the van
when she was following them that was a
long time
ago was the same that was before the
before he became this black suit symo
was that before
Oh that's what let Dr Connor oh
okay wow Andrew jeez I must have spaced
thought I thought that was after that
for some
reason
Harry this guy's always showing up in
helicopters oh damn Harry took a nice
beating on are you hurt I'm fine we both
are but the foundation I don't care
about that right
now are you sure you're okay I really
love how they capture Norman's love for
hero yeah because you didn't really feel
that as much in at least in the Ry
versions well even in the mark but you
really get the
damage
he's usually Us in most adaptations you
just get the sternness of Norman you
know yeah I mean he created a bioweapon
to try to save him in the first game so
we have to focus on finding Dr Connors
and getting you healthy
again I got
this I'm so worried that about Harry at
the end for this game
so far in the first two games an
important character usually goes I mean
so much of the good in that Foundation
was from Harry and I and I think they're
destroying a lot of the light in him
that was like it where a lot of his Hope
was placed so I could see him being
stripped down what a cool this is no
hunt to be proud of he stain on my
legacy a disgrace sure but deadly
nonetheless find
them kill them Craven how many more
people are on this guy's
list drone it's using this satellite
Network to track his targets you're not
getting away that
easy a hey
Dad could really use your help right
now I'm doing everything I can to find
Lee but nothing's wrong
working I know what you say it's not
what you'd want a hero is someone who
doesn't give up and I'm
not I just don't know what else to
[Music]
do maybe I should just ignore everything
else and spend all my time trying to
find
Lee
no if people need help I'm
helping and I'll find
Lee too
busy I'm Spider-Man it's so interesting
his storyline like he doesn't have that
suit in terms of uh but he's got so much
emotional compromise like about Lee
heard someone tag your
shop yes it was hideous until someone
else showed up and painted over it such
detailed work best thing to ever happen
to me it's like The Equalizer has never
boomed no bloomed like wonder if it was
Haley is
gorgeous well when you see them tell
them I said thank you oh here she is you
going thank her
yourself hey
hey Miss thank you for your
services when you guys got to start
dating
right
oh you get to play as Haley hey they
even auditory wise they change oh yeah
good good
call that is really interesting putting
you in the perspective of this where you
have forces you as a viewer to
experience it just through Visual
language and
mhm I wonder why the choice to make you
play is Haley though like to actually go
and do
[Music]
this what a fascinating
experience
really show you the challenges being
here and
impaired you can inspire people through
ART where is this plot line
going
full plot lines this seems the most like
I like it because it's so like tonal and
Atmospheric but at the same time I'm
going where what are we doing this
exactly so far everything has had quite
a payoff so
damn how they get it up to the top
there looks good
after all that she still looks so
disinterested
it's just like the Matrix re reloaded
you do not know someone to do you truly
fight
them you don't know someone to you
Kayla Kayla is that an important name
Kayla I needed to make sure you were the
one you could have just
asked
wow is this a good place to not have
your mask on sure I mean most people in
the community here know right there's
definitely people in the community that
know him obviously at the end of the
last game but still like there's people
in the community that also don't know I
thought you were here buying flowers for
them
see you later I wonder if they
deliver love how that energy just
radiates through the
suit okay
easy I hope those kids enjoy the Autumn
Sunshine wonder if that's just a
byproduct of the suit or is that like
his bio El electricity going through the
suit I think it's that what you're
saying let's hope Connor's is home is
this what we
saw
maybe Dr
[Music]
Connors